في اللحظة التي سقط فيها صاروخ روسي
على مبنى سكني في عطلة عيد الفصح
في
أوديسا ، كانت عائلة يوري جلودين بالداخل
تنتظر عودته من متجر البقالة
في طريق العودة إلى المنزل ، عندما سمعت
انفجارًا شعرت على الفور بأن شيئًا
سيئًا قد حدث حاولت الاتصال به
زوجتي لم تجب عندما وصل إلى هناك
فوضى من
الشرطة ووصل
إي إم إس ، وركض أحد المارة لمحاولة العثور على
عائلته ،
وبدأنا في إزالة الأنقاض
، وهكذا تمكنا إلى جانب موظفي إي إم إس
من العثور على جثث
قُتلت عائلتي جميعًا
أولاً ، ووجدوا جثة حماته
لودميلا ثم جثة زوجته ولكن
ابنته البالغة من العمر ثلاثة أشهر كانت مفقودة
، وقد طُلب منهم المغادرة خوفًا
من انهيار مبنى كنت
أصرخ باستمرار ويقول إنه لا يزال هناك
طفلة هناك هل وجدت الطفلة أم لم يجدوها في
النهاية جسدها الصغير
هامدًا ، عاد ليجد
عربة طفلها المليئة بالدماء في اليوم التالي
، من الصعب العيش مع هذا عائلتي.
طوال حياتي كنت أعيش من أجلهم
عندما جاء طفلي ، فهمت
معنى الحياة ، يقول إن الطفل البالغ من العمر
تسعة عشر عامًا
يعتقد أنه لا يزال على قيد الحياة كان في
نفس المجمع السكني ،
وأرسل الانفجار ألواحًا من الخرسانة الساخنة
والشظايا إلى
أدركت جسده أن صاروخًا قد أصاب
مكاني وبدأت في الاحتراق ، يقول
أنني اعتقدت دقيقة أخرى وسأنتقل
بالتأكيد إلى رماد ، شعرت أن
كل شيء
عشرين بالمائة من جسده قد احترق
في يديه وذراعيه وظهر
الشظايا المسننة يجب أن  يتم
إزالته من ساقيه كما
أنه لا يستطيع القيام بأشياء بسيطة لنفسه
في الوقت الحالي ، لكنه ممتن
لمجرد كونه على قيد الحياة ،
إنها معجزة للجميع بالنسبة لي
كما قال
قبل الانفجار الذي كان يستعد
لنقله إلى البحار والعمل عليه
سفينة إمداد تجارية الآن وهو
يتدرب على المشي مرة أخرى
جاره الذي كان محاطًا بالعائلة
يسير بمفرده الآن في
كل مكان يذهب إليه الآن في أوديسا
لتذكير بما أخذ منه صاروخ روسي
زوجته تشي
مات وحماته الآن ودفن مع
كل ضربة قاتلة قصة جديدة ومروعة
ولدت في أوكرانيا
أنت